[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome to another episode of
whatsa Prof hello
Walter hi
Martin well it feels like ages ago that
we've said this
but we've we kept on rolling the whole
time yes we had a good time in the US
I'm I'm sure everybody saw that a
blessed time and uh I think people will
be glad to see the old format back yes
so it's back not because we changed or
changed our
opinion it's uh back because we now have
a gap to do it we have started the
school of evangelism it's been very very
hectic time so I was very grateful for
those testimonies that could fill the
Gap while we were getting all that stuff
going
yeah and now it's time to get back to
actual events because there are some
very interesting things that are
happening and viewpoints that seem to be
challenged and changed so yes we have to
look at a few of these things yes before
we do that let's let's
pray I heavenly father thank you that we
can still be blessed by a daily uh
doings that you give to us and thank you
that we can do these episodes we ask
that you Enlighten our minds
and keep us through all these
discussions in Jesus name amen
amen yeah M some topics can make one
very hot under the
collar but one has to stay
calm look at the situation and if
necessary uh say something in order to
warn people that they're not trapped in
some yeah in some false Direction well
one of the best ways to fight error is
with truth yes so I've titled this one
contradiction and M this comes of course
from the
Bible and uh one of the things I like
about the King James version is that it
is a direct
translation so you get the essence of
what God Said and not what somebody has
mulched over and think that God said
yeah yeah and just by the way I think
our backdrop uh is quite appropriate for
the occasion for
sure it's always a contradiction when it
has to do with God and Satan yes
absolutely so Martin let us look at this
word
contradiction Hebrews 12:3 for consider
him that endured such contradiction of
Sinners against
himself lest you be wearied and faint in
your
minds so what did Jesus have to endure
what kind of contradiction what does the
word exactly mean there's another verse
where this appears in Acts 13:45 and
when the Jews saw the multitudes they
were filled with envy and spoke against
those things which were spoken by Paul
contradicting and black
blaspheming so
obviously there's something going on
here that we should have a look at so
what is the word the word comes the word
contradiction comes from two Latin Parts
Contra meaning against and dicta meaning
to speak which we usually see as dick or
dict so contradiction is speaking
against something saying no that's wrong
so it's the opposite is true that's what
will say so if you go to the Greek the
word there that is translated
contradiction is
anogia which means contradiction all
right and what does it exactly mean well
to dispute derived from anti opposite to
speaking to a
conclusion contrary conclusion so you
say one thing and they're saying
something else it's almost sound that
word almost sounds like an an logical of
anti logic yes but the word dick you
also get the word dictate dictate yeah
so it is going against the word MH so
Jesus said something they say the
opposite so they're going against the
word of God that that going the opposite
direction and loia means words or disco
so hypothetical collection either
written or oral or of the sayings of
Jesus so going anti logia against the
word of God that's what it means now how
does God speak to us he speaks to us in
his word and through His prophets that's
how he
speaks so the Greek word logos
traditionally meaning word thought
principle or speech has been used
amongst both philosophers and
theologians so contradiction is going
against the word of God
basically what it means there's another
word that's interesting in the Bible and
that is or that's interesting in general
is
controversy it means disputation debate
prolonged agitation of contrary
opinions and would you agree that there
is a great controversy between Christ
and sat definitely they are two
opposites so they have contrary opinions
yeah and we are charged to make a choice
either the one opinion or the other
opinion now Martin it seems to me there
has been a
contradiction and there has been a
controversy going on within our ranks
lately M and one of the articles that
appeared in Spectrum was titled
navigating
change adventism and Catholicism in a
shifting
world and basically some of the
theologians out there and some of these
were Union presidents in the past
Etc uh apped that Catholicism has
changed so one of them was Dr Rea
brunsma distinguished Adventist
theologians according to
Spectrum and he addressed an eager crowd
at notra Vista High
School and the event was titled
adventism and Catholicism in a changing
world and there were a couple of people
involved such as Dr Gilbert Valentine a
retired Adventist historian Dr Gary at
charti associate Dean at lasierra
University School of Business and
prolific author and then father eie
okoma Roman Catholic priest and chaplain
at Loma Linda University Medical Center
and together they explored the evolving
relationship between Adventists and
Catholics so basically what they're
propagating is that Catholicism has
changed and saying that we can no longer
cling to our outdated views on the these
issues now number of years ago I had a
little altercation with Dr Randa brunsma
that went to the
internet and people can type in that
name and my name and they'll probably
get hold of it because these are not new
views those are old
views uh that periodically come forward
in order to change the mindset of people
yeah and I don't normally mention names
or anything like that but there are some
interesting institutions Lera and Lama
Linda and all of these and I'm not
saying that as a institution in
totality that the people will have these
views but lasera for example is one that
has been very liberal over the ages also
in terms of the creation evolution
debate and uh therefore I would be very
reticent when it comes to some of their
thinking and at a big university such as
LMA Linda there's probably a lot of
debate going on and I think you can
expect both sides of that Spectrum but
why do I want to talk about it or why
are we going to talk about it because I
believe it's dangerous yeah I I believe
it is so dangerous that it could become
salvational because it will take you
away from where your o should be yes for
sure and therefore I think it needs to
be addressed irrespective of the names
forget about the names the names are not
important no because if they aren't
there they'll be others there'll be
others the one will disappear the next
one will take his place this is
something that will continue until the
close of time but it is an attempt to
change the mindset of God's people
that's for sure and this is very very
dangerous and therefore I think it's
time to speak up I'm not saying that
these people are affiliated in any
particular way or not I have no evidence
to that effect but I find it strange
that they should engage in these modes
of thinking while claiming to be Seventh
Day Advent yes I have the same
sentiments to be
part of a certain group you have to
adhere to the requirements to be part of
that certain group and you know we're
dealing with the with the school of
evangelism at the moment and we're
talking about Remnant yes and a Remnant
is those that keep the Commandments and
hold to the
testimony it's very important that it
doesn't say consider the testimony it
says hold to the testimony and what is
the testimony it's the spirit of
Prophecy MH the testimony of of Jesus so
when God speaks through a prophet it is
the testimony of Jesus yes that means
it's the word absolutely and
counteracting the word means to be
contradicting yes and those who
contradict Jesus are in that verse
called
Sinners so it's not us saying this no
it's God's word saying this so let's
listen to the speech
that was made at that
occasion and I want to suggest some ways
in which Catholics and Adventist can
actually learn from each
other the readers of my book will note
that Adventists have at least
officially continued to insist
throughout its
history that Roman Catholicism has not
fundamental
changed and that it will not change in
the
future the Roman Church may as Adventist
Pioneer Alan white
suggested now present a fair front to
the
world but it remains unchanged and quote
beneath the variable appearance of the
chameleon he that is the Catholic Church
conceals the invariable Venom of the
serpent
and
quote I believe it is time to distance
ourselves from this
characterization the medieval Church of
the centuries before
tent and even the Church of Vatican 1 is
not the same church as the community
that Pope Francis uh we stopped it at
that point because I fear that my and
your colar could just erupt that will
not that will not work right all right
would you call that a contradiction oh
for sure now the same author has in the
past
reneg the spirit of Prophecy to the 19th
century and not applicable to
us and that also contradicts statement
which say they are applicable till the
end of
time so Martin when we look at this
navigating the change has Roman
Catholicism changed and if so can we now
embrace it and work together with it as
is happening at some of our
institutes because this theology is
obviously gaining a foothold oh for sure
it's very prominent these days yes
Martin is that putting your head in the
proverbial sand or is that just open
rebellion and contradiction
I think it
going maybe a little bit more of the
other than the sand part all right now
firstly let's just uh recap the word of
God in Daniel chapter 2 and Daniel
chapter 7 we have two very distinct
prophecies and they tell us where we are
in the Stream of time and what happened
over history and in Daniel chapter 7 you
go through the king
from The Lion representing Babylon to
the me Persian bear to the
foreheaded uh leopard beast and then the
terrible Beast with the 10 horns and
then a very prominent horn between the
eyes and this is the one that will be
different from the others and it shall
be prescriptive in the
world now this particular prophecy is so
incredibly
accurate that as Graton guines said in
his book it's like one of those keys
that fits a chub's lock yeah and refuses
point blank to adapt to any
other because the attributes of this
little horn power that all Protestant
reformers associated with the
papacy was that it arose out of the
fourth Beast of Daniel other word it is
Roman yeah it also arose amongst the 10
horns according to verse 8 which means
it's a
European power it arises after Rome
Pagan Rome had been divided into 10
according to verse
24 so just from those verses alone we
know that uh it's a European
power and we know
when it arises after the division of the
Roman Empire and it is the one that is
different from all the others because it
is also an ecclesiastical power yes
religious
yes it becomes more Stout than the
others although it grows from littleness
it becomes prescriptive towards the
others verse
20 then Three Kingdoms the herui the
vizos and the ostr gos were uprooted
before it could take
power verse 20 and then it is an
overseer it has eyes like a man it
speaks great word and it is a
Blasphemous power because it speaks
against the most high could we say it is
contradictory
yes okay exactly and he speaks great
things pompous words according to verse
8 and verse 25 it's also a persecuting
power because it wears out the Saints of
the most
high now
modern it also changes times and laws it
changes God's laws and the times which
God has set according to verse
25 there's a very specific time period
in which it will have this political
power and this this time period a time
time and half a time is given in many
forms in the Bible 42 months 1 260 days
3 and a half years time time and half a
time and they always apply to the same
power because Hebrew parallelism tells
you that there's a woman there's a
Wilderness there's a time there's a
woman woman there's a Wilderness there's
a time and all of these times are
mentioned in that
framework and then it will become so
powerful that the whole world will be
subject to it and it will exist until
the end of time
so obviously that power exists now
because it arises after the division of
the Roman Empire and it exists until now
until yeah so there's not a it cannot be
some already fulfilled or in the future
it is already it's still there it is
there and then its Dominion will be
taken away and it will be destroyed so
obviously it is not a very uh let's say
conducive power when it comes to the
Bible it is
contradictory all the
reformers identified it with the papacy
because to get every single point
including the time prophecy to apply is
impossible but this has happened so the
the chances of it happening are one to
the number of particles and the entire
universe the reformers were so adamant
about it that they hued it in stone in
one of their Reformation cities NB and
they put it on the town hall to make
sure that nobody forgets who and what
was depicted
there Martin Luther and all the
reformers said I know that the pope is
Antichrist and that his seat is that of
Satan himself the papacy is a general
chase by command of the Roman pontiff
for the purpose of running down and
destroying Souls that was pretty direct
language is which is not suitable in an
ecumenical climate today not at all and
this comes from almost like Paul was a
Jew of the Jews he was a Catholic of a
cath of the Catholics correct and and
not on him Malon said it grandma said it
Ridley said it uh all of them said it
Calvin said it John Knox said it it
doesn't matter who we are talking to or
talking about in the Reformation line
they all recognized it from Daniel
that's exactly and that's why Martin
Luther said Daniel is so important that
he was going to translate it first when
it came to the Old Testament translation
well even Jesus said how important was
Daniel yes now according to these these
gentlemen Rome has
changed well when the Reformation put
out this challenge event a council was
called after much turmoil much
Bloodshed persecution Wars and that was
the Council of
Trent now at the Council of Trent
decisions were made as to what the
status quo should be and Protestants
were present at that Council by command
of the
king now did the Council of Trent accept
any of Luther's
paradigms no
no now if Rome changed
MH then they must have repudiated every
principle adopted at the Council of
Trent yes because they negated every
single doctrine of the Protestant
Reformation
yeah so when Bishop Schneider was
confronted with the heresies of Martin
Luther as the Roman Catholics call them
it's interesting to listen to his
response and this was recent recently
yes it's also interesting to note that
the Architects M of the Council of Trent
and of every subsequent Council whether
it be Vatican 1 or Vatican 2 councils
were the Jesuits yeah and the Jesuits
openly
claim that uh a lie in order to further
the ideals of the Roman Catholic Church
is perfectly
acceptable as is murder or anything
else not only that Martin not only are
they allowed to do that but they allowed
to be
clandestine they go
underground and uh this is also
interesting because Bishop Schneider is
addressing a question where the papacy
said that Martin Luther was actually
okay where Pope Francis said that mhm on
a on a discussion on an aeroplane with a
reporter and he said you know those
discussions were informal they they are
not Catholic Doctrine the only thing
that is Catholic Doctrine is when the
pope speaks from The Bishop's seat yes
and the je and and the present Pope
being a Jesuit obviously he aligns
himself with the Jesuit ideology which
means lying is perfectly acceptable
so let's hear what Bishop Schneider has
to say your your Excellency thank you
for being here today my question is
since the discussion is about heresy one
heretic who comes to mind is Martin
Luther Who 500th anniversary of the
Reformation uh the pope will be
commemorating um in very very shortly uh
on an airplane interview the pope
recently said that Mar Luther did not
eror on the issue of justification what
is your response to the Lutheran heresy
and uh on the issue of justification and
the upcoming ecumenical events and how
to traditional Catholics respond to uh
the reports that are coming
out they have already had an infalible
response to the errors of Martin Luther
the Council of Trent
[Applause]
of the Council of trans about the erors
of Luther I repeat are
infallible ex
Cathedral and the commands of the Pope
in the plane are not
excal
so according to Bishop
Schneider the Council of Trent is
definitive because it's ex Cathedral the
pope was speaking infallibly yes all
right so let's have a look at some of
these issues because it becomes
important for our
discussion the Jesuits and Ultram
monism
ultramontanism is all power in one man
it used to be a a mock title for the
papacy Ultra montain other side the
mountain but it became a positive they
they took a negative and posit posi ized
it and made it all power in one
man so in the 17th century Ultra
ultramontanism became closely associated
with the Jesuits who defended the
superiority of popes over councils and
Kings even in temporal
questions so within the Roman Catholic
Church Ultram monism achieved victory
over
conciliarism in other words you can't be
consiliary you can't make compromises
the word of the pope is absolute even if
it contradicts God his word
precedes so at the first Vatican council
with a pronouncement of papal
infallibility the ability of the Pope to
Define dogmas free from error ex cadra
MH free from error and that ex cathedra
sitting on The Bishop's chair correct
proclaiming that's what Bishop Schneider
just referred to and of papal Supremacy
I.E Supreme full immediate and Universal
ordinary jurisdiction of the Pope other
Christians not in full communion with r
declared this as the Triumph of what
they ter the heresy of
ultramontanism to declare yourself
infallible is to make yourself equal
with God it is a heresy but it is held
by the Roman Catholic church and if
something has been said ex cadra because
of this Dogma it cannot be changed so
how can Rome by its own definition
change can cannot right does that make
sense it's
there it's as plain as that okay if I
tell you something then you cannot tell
me that what I'm saying to you is isn't
worth anything because I'm saying it
correct so when we go to re
13:3 and it says I saw one of his heads
because this conglomerate beast in
Revelation 13 is a complete hieroglyph
of the Roman Catholic papacy it is
identical to the little horn pow we just
get a little bit more detail so it
receives a deadly wound as a beast that
is a political entity so at some stage
it loses its political power not its
ecclesiastical power
power but that wound would be healed and
the whole world would receive its
mindset wondered after the
beast that's according to scripture and
the reformers were all of One Accord
that this was a reference to Rome the
interesting thing is that they were
convinced that it was so
before this entity received a mortal
wound in 1798 and its political power
was taken away fulfilling the time frame
Prophecy of the
Bible and they knew this to be the
papacy even with those events still
being future at that time that's amazing
yeah for sure and Wesley actually said
just before that time period it must be
very close now because this time period
is coming to an end they were amazing
they were amazing and they were
spoton all right and so the Jesuits were
called to counter the
Reformation by whatever means even if it
meant
assassination
impersonation whatever means they became
the school masters of
Europe and they became the educators of
the presidents and the elite of the
world and uh they were ordained in
1540 by by Pope Paul III so here they
Reed their marching
orders and this is what some of these
sentiments were this is Catholic sources
protestantism is not a religion never
was a religion the most that could be
said about it was that it was a form of
rape and robbery masquerading as a
religion if you go to the main Church of
the Jesuits in Rome they have this
statue of mother Church destroying
Calvin and Luther and this mischievous
Little Gnome of an Angel tearing up
Martin Luther's writings namely the
Bible so they vowed to destroy it they
vowed to destroy it so at the Council of
Trent what doctrines were reaffirmed EX
cathedra
infallible
infallibly
transubstantiation oh in other words
that the bread literally became the body
of Christ and that the mass was a
Perpetual sacrifice a repetition of the
exact sacrifice that Christ brought when
the Bible clearly says by one sacrifice
he has forever made perfect has that
ever been repudiated has that ever been
withdrawn no no number two justification
by faith and
works they will tell you that they have
now reached a Concord but they changed
the terminology from by faith alone to
grace
alone and we've dealt with that in many
cases so what they signed the joint
Declaration of justification the
Protestants and the Catholics was
actually Catholic Doctrine yes very
cleverly
phrased number three
the medieval Mass was
upheld but Jesus instituted the Last
Supper in its place as a symbol of a
completed sacrifice because by one
sacrifice he has forever made perfect
fourth the seven sacraments were
confirmed now in Catholic thinking
Martin a Sacrament is salvation yeah so
baptism for example is a sacrament so if
you were not baptized you didn't come
into the realm of
Salvation so the Roman Catholic Church
invented something called
Limbo where babies that unfortunately
were not baptized went because they
couldn't go to Purgatory to burn off
their sins yeah or the guilt of their
sins so they went to limbo but
fortunately Pope Benedict the
predecessor of Pope
Francis got rid of limbo I don't know
what happened to all the
babies but uh it said that this
philosophy was not really ex cedra so
they could get rid of it but patry could
never get rid of because that was ex
cadra right so celibacy was maintained M
although Paul distinctly said that the
Antichrist would forbid to marry and the
only religious Institute that does that
to its Ecclesia is the Roman Catholic
Church then the doctrine of purgatory
was maintained now the doctrine of
purgatory says literally
Martin that you pay for your own sins
even those that are forgiven so Christ
never bore the penalty that is Jesuit
Doctrine we call that an esoteric an
inner Doctrine held by the
Jesuits but to the outside
they play it down so that the outside
world
doesn't accept that that they don't
actually agree with the atonement so
they have a different Doctrine Purgatory
is the guarantee that they don't believe
in the atonement because you have to pay
for your own sin finished indulgences
were reaffirmed so you can buy your way
out you can buy your way out of patry
and only the pope can release you not
even God can he has to subscribe to the
sentence of the priest
this is such diabolical Doctrine and so
anti-rip and it's ex cathedra which is
infallible it's infallible they can
never change by definition they cannot
change and Papal power was increased by
giving the Pope the authority to enforce
thees of the decrees of the council and
requiring Church officials to promise
him obedience and then at the first
Vatican Council he was declared
infallible
putting a stamp yeah on what they were
saying this is really in your face it's
blasphemy it's Blas for me right what's
the Jesuit catechism have to say this is
amazing question what if the holy
scriptures command one thing and the
pope another contrary to it is that a
contradiction
Mar
directly sure well the answer is the
holy scriptures must
be not put aside m throne throne aside
they called it that poisonous ASP
remember and then what is the pope he is
the Vicor of Christ king of kings and
Lord of lords and there is but one
judgment seat belonging to God and the
pope So He makes himself God is that
blasphemy exactly that there's no better
description and this is the Jesuit
catechism now I've always maintained
that the
Jesuits I will not give give that
definition now Martin because I would
probably get into trouble right they are
the most well isn't it a quote it's a
quote from yes so then you
can they are those champions of popery
Martin that have used every diabolical
means to uh obtain their ends they
really were a disgrace to humanity and
an affront to God to this very day in my
opinion and in the opinion of thousands
of historians for sure and the spirit of
Prophecy will agree correct if we go a
little bit further and we look at
Maguire's catechism it puts it this way
Bishops and Priests of the church are
called other
christs they alone have the power to
represent or to take the place of Christ
in preaching his go gospel and in
offering his sacrifice for the glory of
God and the salvation of
men that is a blasphemy in
itself through his ordination a priest
is supposed to receive special
Supernatural Powers particularly to
change Bread and Wine into the body and
blood of Christ in the Holy sacrifice of
the mass and to forgive sins in the
sacrament of penance so this is their
catechism this is the new Baltimore
catechism and the Bible calls these
statements blasphemy yeah because they
wanted to Stone Jesus for blasphemy for
saying he can forgive sins that's it
contradicting their thoughts yes now
were they satisfied with contradicting
everything that the Protestant
Reformation had uncovered no no they
added a little bit of mustard to to
their brew and in 1854 they declared
Mary
Immaculate now that's amazing Martin
because they declared Mary Immaculate so
that the Redeemer could be born from her
yeah that means Martin that she was
without sin in the original sinless
state but without the shedding of blood
there's no forgiveness of sins now
Martin if God could declare Mary
Immaculate without a sacrifice couldn't
he do the same for you and for me for
anybody doesn't that make the sacrifice
of Christ obsolete joke null and void
there's no purpose
1951 Pope Pas defined and enforced the
doctrine of the bodily Assumption of
Mary there are at least three graves in
the world where Mary is laid one in the
Orthodox Church one in the Catholic one
and it's it's a a total confusion yeah
because now one in the Middle East
somewhere she's
ascended so well if she had no sin then
she didn't become a subject of death
right and so she ascended to Heaven is
there anything like that in the Bible no
no the Catholic nonon in 1856 said The
Sinner that Ventures directly to Christ
may come with Dread and apprehension of
his wroth but let him only employ the
mediation of the virgin with her son and
she has only to show that son the
breasts that gave him suck and his wrath
will immediately be appeased have you
ever heard something so disgusting as
that what does that do to the character
of Christ oh twists it is contradicting
it have they withdrawn any of these
statements no
never so let's go to
2003 Rome's challenge most Christians
assume that Sunday is the biblically
approved day of worship the Roman
Catholic Church protests that it
transferred Christian worship from the
biblical Sabbath Saturday to Sunday and
that to try to argue that the change was
made in the Bible is both dishonest and
a denial of Catholic Authority if
Protestants want to base its religion
only on the Bible it should worship on
Saturday so Rome is throwing down the
gauntlet and said listen guys we changed
God's law yeah and if you say that it
was changed in the Bible you are denying
our Authority we changed it because we
are above the Bible yeah they're
gloating they're gloating arrogance of
the highest
order two doctrines that come from
Jesuit pens preterism and futurism why
did they invent them Martin to take the
focus away from the true Antichrist the
true true enemy right so the Bible
identified the Antichrist who the Bible
so if you contradict the Bible you're
contradicting Jesus Christ exactly if
you contradict these prophets you are
contradicting the testimony of Jesus in
other words you're contradicting the
word of Jesus that's
it so the first one was
preterism alaza came up with this idea
by the preterist interpretation all the
prophecies relating to Antichrist were
pushed back in an Endeavor to find their
fulfillment before the collapse of the
Roman
Empire Daniel clearly said he comes out
of the fourth Kingdom and he comes up
amongst the horns and after they already
formed yeah so it's Roman
right so let's just see where this comes
from Modern alaza a Spanish Jesuit
taking a hint from Victorinos seems to
have been the first in ad.
1614 to have suggested that the
apocalyptic prophecies did not extend
further than the overthrow of paganism
by
Constantine so it's been usual to say
that the Spanish Jesuit
alaza in his uh publication was the
founder of the preterist school I had a
discussion with a Protestant Minister
who still believed that and he insisted
that it was the Greek king antioc that
qualifies as the Antichrist although the
Bible says that he came out of the
fourth Beast and must therefore be Roman
existed from its division to the End of
Time therefore he must be here now and
he couldn't dispute
that but he still insisted to contradict
the word of God and make it a Greek king
is this a contradiction 100% so
obviously I can assume that alaza was
sinning against the word of God that's
it and anybody who contradicts the word
of God is a sinner that's it so an
investigation into the hidden sense of
the Apocalypse are just some historical
sources now what about
futurism Rea took those same prophecies
and H them off into the future declaring
that the Antichrist would make his
appearance after the coming of Christ so
Rea published a commentary in
1585 containing these
ideas of course Martin these ideas have
been modified of late Rapture has been
brought in but in any case the one threw
the Antichrist into the past so nobody
is ever affected by it after the
Reformation the other one threw him into
the future when the Christian world had
already been taken away by Christ or
whatever so the Antichrist only actually
came and were here for the unfaith
correct so all the teachings of the
reformers were made null and void by the
these two now people with a little bit
of Savvy when they study these things
must realize that he can't be you
know
preterism because he comes out of Rome
and not out of Greece but why is it that
the Christian World embraced
futurism well I think I have a answer to
that because it makes them see God as
loving them more if I can put it like
that because they believe why would God
want them to go through everything
that's bad if they can be taken away ah
so they're going to be raptured
beforehand all right so Protestants
today are divided between modernists and
fundamentalists modernists give little
or no place to the study of Prophecy and
fundamentalists are in the main today
futurists but some conservative
Protestants are still
preterist so Rea was again a Jesuit
doctor of theology born in Spain began
writing a lengthy commentary in
1585 but this was designedly done to
counteract the theology on the
Antichrist of the Protestant okay and if
you go back to what you just mentioned
earlier what was the purpose of the
Jesuits to counteract and Destroy
protestantism so this was published then
in
1519 so that's just
after the Reformation which started in
1517 here is a quote from the book
romanism and the Reformation written in
the late
1800s by a church of England
Theologian Gran guines and he wrote then
to resist the use to which scripture
prophecy was put by the reformers is no
light or unimportant matter so I would
like to suggest to our modern
antagonists and
contradictories that it is no light or
unimportant matter to contradict what
the reformers had said true on the
issue the system of prophetic
interpretation known as
futurism does resist this use it
condemns the interpretation of the
reformers it condemns the views of all
these men and of all the martyrs and of
all the confessors and faithful
Witnesses of Christ for long centuries
it condemns the alanes and the valdenses
the whites the hites the lards the
lutherans the Calvinists it condemns
them all and upon a point upon which
they are all agreed an interpretation of
scripture which they embodied in their
solemn confessions and SE f with their
blood does that apply today or is this
ancient history it cannot be and if you
are saying this isn't so you're
contradicting this 100% you're actually
contradicting the whole Reformation
reformation and you are saying the
Reformation wasn't from God exactly then
it must have been from the devil yes
because there are only two that are
contradictory when it comes to this
point and that's a very scary thing to
do because when you start calling what's
from God that is from the devil that
dabling in the sin against the Holy
Spirit that's a very dangerous position
to be in that's why it's important that
we discuss this anybody who follows in
these footsteps makes themselves guilty
of the same offense The Book of
Revelation has a very Stark warning and
a very great blessing to those that read
it but if you contradict it fire comes
out of them and destroys
you now another one who embellished the
these doctrines was a man by the name of
bellamine of course another Jesuit
Cardinal of course this is their job one
of the best known Jesuit apologists
published a work between 1581 and 1593
entitled
whatever concerning the disputed points
of the Christian belief against Heretics
of this time in which he also denied the
day year principle course in Prophecy
and pushed the reign of antichrist into
the future period of three and a half
literal
years now Martin that is destroying
prophetic
interpretation and the guidelines which
are given in scripture
themselves this is contradicting the
word of God this is a very dangerous
thing to do so M let me read you another
quote not from me
was one of the gentlemen involved in
this uh modernday attack on the reformed
position uh was very offended that I
should even mention secret
societies in the in the circumstances of
today here is a quote not from me but
from the book The Grand isign exposed
and it says the truth is the Jesuits of
Rome have perfected Freemasonry to be
their most magnificent and effective
tool accomplishing their purposes
amongst
Protestants and Martin if I had to look
at the Freemasons that were involved in
protestantism then whether I'm talking
about the Robert schoers of this world
or many of the mega preachers of the
world they were all associated with
Freemasonry Norman Vincent Peele was a
33 degree Freemason he was the mentor of
Billy Graham etc etc the the list is
endless so this cannot be disputed or
put into the Realms of conspiracy
theories at all so M let's go to the
spirit of Prophecy and see what that had
to say now he quoted one of the
statements the one about the chameleon
in the video that we showed but we'll
keep that for for later let's take a
look at a few others pop is just what
prophecy declared that she should be the
apostasy of the latter times have we
seen that in their doctrines oh yeah for
sure have any of them been withdrawn or
repudiated no it is a part of her policy
to assume the character which will best
accomplish her
purpose but beneath the variable
appearance of the chameleon she conceals
the invariable Venom of the serpent this
is what he quoted right yes we are not
bound to keep faith and promise to
Heretics she declares she can even lie
right yeah the comments on of the Pope
on the airplane wer excuted so he can
say really what he wants to
right shall this power whose record for
a thousand years is written in the blood
of saints be now acknowledged as part of
the Church of
Christ pretty plain
right the church that holds to the word
of God is irreconcilably separated from
Rome Protestants were once thus apart
from this great church of apostasy but
they have approached more nearly to her
and are still in the path of
reconciliation to the Church of Rome
this comes from the review in Herald and
was written in
1886 uh Randa brinar said this is 19th
century literature and we should
disregard it Rome never
changes you know Martin if he would
realize that they can't change because
they're infallible yeah they can't
change without disrupting their entire
theology her principles have not altered
in the least she has not lessened the
breach between herself and Protestants
they have done all the
advancing but what does this argue for
the protestantism of this day it is the
rejection of Bible truth which makes men
approach to infidelity it is a
backsliding church that lessens the
distance between itself and the
papacy and this is the religion which
Protestants are beginning to look upon
with so much favor and which will
eventually be United with protestantism
do we need this in our own
ranks no for definitely not if you this
is also a prophecy yes it's a prophecy
and it's come true yes so of course it's
come true if you are part of this
fulfillment of prophecy you have to
decide where you standing correct the
union will not however be affected by a
change in Catholicism for Rome never
changes she claims
infallibility it is protestantism that
will change the adoption of liberal
ideas on its part will bring it where it
can clasp the hands of Catholicism and
Martin if it happens within our church
then it's time to raise our voices and
to warn the people if you want to avoid
the fire yes that comes out of the m
then stay away from this kind of
theology because God's people are called
to expose the wickedness of the man of
sin in the very time in which we live
the Lord has called his people and has
given them a message to Bear is called
them to expose the wickedness of the man
of sin not to become conciliatory and to
go into ecumenical relations with him we
don't have to read it all just suffice
to say people are are to be shown what
they may expect from the papal power so
when people out there ask why are you
always talking about it it's a matter of
life and death exactly and then you hear
contradictory statements made by people
that should know better if you don't if
you want to make statements like that
then go and join their their ranks yes
go and join them become a cardinal like
Cardinal Newman did or go and join
another denomination but this one is
supposed to expose the wickedness of the
man of sin and what is more in the book
evangelist it says that this terrible
picture drawn by John this is in the
Revelation to show how completely the
powers of Earth will give themselves
over evil should show those who have
received the truth how dangerous it is
to link up with secret societies or to
join themselves in any way with those
who do not keep the Commandments of God
we could go now and show picture after
picture after picture of protestant
Freemasons contradicting the word of God
yeah but we don't have to because it's
replete and people can go and look at it
in history for themselves so according
to the statement our secret societies
involved in this conflict in re in
Revelation for sure another quote from
the great controversy the popery that
Protestants are now so ready to honor is
the same that ruled the world in the
days of the Reformation when men of God
stood up at the Peril of their lives to
expose her iniquity she possesses the
same pride and arrogant assumption that
lorded it over Kings and princes and
claimed the prerogatives of God her
spirit is no less cruel and despotic now
than when she crushed out human Liberty
and slew the Saints of the most high
they are negating this statement yes
because they're throwing it it's old old
um statements it doesn't really anymore
but I wonder what the Jesuits who
fermented all those revolutions and
wiped out any contradiction to them
would say to these issues how the Roman
Church can clear herself from the chge
of idolatry we cannot
see and this is the religion which
Protestants are beginning to look upon
with so much favor and will eventually
be United with protestantism the union
will however not be affected by a change
in Catholicism for Rome never changes
we've read this before I just want to
emphasize that this is the testimony of
Jesus but you see you can see this the
whole time it's a repetition of History
nothing new Under the Sun nothing new it
happened again now and again they say oh
but they've changed but if you look at
everything they didn't retract any what
what they said Rome the Protestants have
changed again correct it's another
statement from four manuscript releases
for the Lord spoke thus to me with a
strong hand and instructed me that I
should not walk in the way of this
people saying say ye Not A Confederacy
to all them whom this people shall say A
Confederacy neither fear ye Their Fear
nor be afraid sanctify the Lord of hosts
himself and let him be your fear and let
him be your dread that's a quote from
Isaiah
right to the law and to The Testament if
they speak not according to this word is
because there is no light in them the
world is not to be our Criterion let the
Lord work let the Lord's voice be heard
so here is a Confederacy that Isaiah
predicts in those that oppose God's
testimony and his law do you want to be
in that category Martin no please I
don't there's to be no alliance with
unbelievers those employed in our
department of the work whereby the word
may be transformed must not enter into
alliance with those who know not the
truth the world know not the father and
the son and they have no spiritual
discernment as to the character of our
work as to what we shall do or not do we
must obey the orders that come from
above we are not to hear the counsel or
follow the pl suggested by unbelievers
if you contradict God's word and the
spirit of Prophecy you're believer
that's it suggestions made by those who
know not the work that God is doing for
this time will be such as to weaken the
power of the instrumentalities of God by
accepting such suggestions the Council
of Christ is set at not you know I was
just thinking you were mention you just
said that those that contradicted his
unbelievers that sounds harsh but it's
true it's true of course because if you
don't believe what the word is telling
you you're an unbeliever you're an
unbeliever and that's it now they will
say but all right the modern papacy has
changed yes you know they always have an
excuse we need men who will not be drawn
into secret underhand
confederacies we need to be very careful
Martin we mustn't take heed of
unpleasant men neither flattery pretend
cunning no art could induce to Swerve
one hair from principle or duty if the
word says it that's where you take your
stand so that flattery and all of that
that it can always be under the G oh but
we have to love the each other correct
it's we don't say don't love each other
we don't say that you should not
um evangelize people that think like
that and don't hand out the great
controversy of course we have to do that
because those people also have to be
warned to come out of that system
correct God's word has given warning of
the impending danger let this be
unheeded and the Protestant world will
learn what the purposes of Rome really
are only when it is too late to escape
the snare she's silently growing into
Power her doctrines are exerting their
influence in legislative Halls is that
happening Martin yes what is the prayer
break breakfast other
than doctrines being professed in legisl
of Halls churches and in the hearts of
men she is piling up her lofty and
massive structures in the secret
recesses of which her former
persecutions will be
repeated stealthily unsuspectedly she is
strengthening her forces to further her
own ends and when the time shall come
for her to strike all that she desires
is Vantage ground and this is already
being given her we shall soon see and
shall feel what the purpose of the Roman
element is whoever Shall Believe and
obey the word of God will thereby incur
reproach and
persecution is negating all of those
words yeah well you see you can see this
because how are people going to react
when everybody says yeah Rome has
changed and you stand there and say no
but it hasn't you look like
uh Source thumb stick sticking out okay
so let's let's see if it's so isn't that
something we should do of course is the
National Catholic Reporter and it tells
us that Pope Francis and Peter Faber are
Kindred Jesuit Spirits in other words
they have the same
mindset now who was Peta FAA he was the
co-founder of the Jesuit order together
with Ignatius
L Pope francis's statements of late in
solidarity with the poor on the need for
community and on refocusing the church's
energies away from a narrow focus on
sexual
issues let's just get away from our
sexual debuchy let's not talk about that
may sound shocking to some this is a
much different tone than the image of
the papacy in recent times in Paris Faba
also encountered ignatus of L
he tuted ignasius on
aristotlean
philosophy remember the Beast has a a
Greek
body while ignasius formed faba's
spirituality under ignatius' guidance
Faba mastered the spiritual
exercises in 1534 he was ordained a
priest and later that year on August 15
he and six other men including ignasius
and Francis savier
took vows as the first members of what
became the Jesuit order they're telling
me over here that Pope Francis has the
same mindset yeah and these people were
instructed to destroy protestantism even
by slaughtering and torturing them in
inquisitions yeah so then obviously it
must have the same Spirit does he have
the same spirit is he that arrogant
isn't he a sweet old man let's ask the
Jesuits of today how we should evaluate
the papacy this is the professor of
moral theology this is Richard M Gula he
says the natural law is Central to Roman
Catholic moral
theology it is the kind of reasoning
which Faith informs perhaps the single
most characteristic feature of
traditional catholic morality is that
the church can teach a morality which is
applicable always everywhere and for
everyone because it relies on natural
law as the basis of teaching that is
Greek
philosophy the advantage of using
natural law is that the church shows
great respect for human human goodness
what does the Bible say about human
goodness there's not one that the heart
is deceitful above all things and
desperately
wicked therefore it needs an external
morality imposed upon it exactly and not
a papal man-based
theology or morality yeah well that's
what their theology makes man God like
they said yes so besides this respect
for human goodness it also trusts the
human capacity to know and choose what
is right so it makes him God that's one
of the first lies of Satan that's it you
will know good and evil by yourself you
don't need God for that also by means of
appealing to natural law the church chur
can address its discussions and claim
for the rightness or wrongness of a
particular action to all persons of good
will not just those who share its
religious conviction so the church
becomes the moral compass and it decides
what is right and what is wrong and not
God he goes on to say one of the great
disadvantages of such an approach is
that can easily lead to handing
Christian morality over to moral
philosophy where in religious beliefs do
not really make a difference for moral
claims the
magisterium now that's the hierarchy of
the Roman Catholic Church the pope and
his Bishops yeah has appealed to natural
law as the basis for its teachings
pertaining to a just Society sexual
behavior medical practice human life
religious freedom and the relation ship
between morality and civil law that's
every aspect of your life yeah who
decides it for you the Mis the misesian
in any case the development of natural
law tradition amongst Christian thinkers
is due not so much to scripture as to
the influence of Greek philosophy and
Roman law it's out of the W's mouth out
of their own mouth this is Jesuit
thinking they've changed this is 1989
contradicting God yeah these are sinners
who contradict God he continues one is
always bound to follow the Judgment of a
properly informed conscience now who
informs your conscience properly Martin
well the real one would be the Bible and
the and the um the Holy Spirit yes this
informant um comes probably from the
magisterium yes let's read the informing
takes place in community
by appealing to various sources of moral
V wisdom I wonder who this moral wisdom
is in the church the magisterial is a
source of moral
Authority so it seems they tolerate all
of these perversities that have filled
the headlines of Roman Catholic
situations throughout these last decades
right a sad State its teaching is very
important they not exclusive factor in
the formation of conscience and of one's
moral
judgment to appeal to Authority is part
of responsible
living in appealing to an authority we
believe that it will be more correct
about this question than we will or than
anyone else to whom we might appeal so
more correct than God himself in the
word of God
Martin isn't that contradicting the word
of God for sure the key text for
understanding the loyal response to
magisterial teaching is in this
encyclical Lum
gentium unbelievable stuff and what do
they
say in matters of faith and morels the
bishop speaks in the Name of Christ and
the faithful accept their teaching and
adhere to it with religious Ascent of
Soul so the pope and his Bishops speak
and you obey like like are God like they
are God this religious submission of
Will and of Mind must be shown in a
special way to the authentic teaching
authority of the Roman pontiff even when
he's not speaking exced so he's actually
contradicting the other guy
h Martin Rome has changed not at all
this guy has really emphasized that it
hasn't changed it has never changed it
is as arrogant and despotic as it ever
was in my treatment of formation of
conscience I pointed out that character
is formed in community that's natural
law Martin so if a community decides
that it has certain deot trays and the
whole Community accepts it then it's
fine it's like cannibalism so the whole
Community accepts it that it's fine then
it makes it moral yes oh anyone Peter
feels or whatever woke category you want
to invoke it's fine even if it
contradicts the word of God all right
so why by committing our freedom to a
particular object of loyalty and then by
internalizing the images rituals
Traditions which the community has
fashioned in order to carry the meaning
attached to that object of loyalty this
is so disgusting I want to get a hot
collar what is this object of loyalty
that you attach yourself to it's the
pope obviously right like he mentioned
in the previous portion the Roman
pontiff and so let's call him the Holy
Father what a blasphemy has R changed no
not at all it's become worse right
actually yes because protestantism has
clasped hands with it and they read this
and they sweep it under the
rock so let's ask them plainly what does
religious Ascent or submission of Will
and mind mean in moral matters this is
Jesuit speaking right religious abent or
submission means that such effort and
appropriation are motivated by the
conviction that Jesus has commissioned
the church to teach and that the Spirit
guides the church in truth so Francis
Sullivan an ecclesiologist from the
Gregorian University in Rome what kind
of university is that a Jesuit un Jesuit
one it's the mother
university has analyzed this expression
in his masterful work
magisterium teaching Authority in the
Catholic church and offers this
summary as I understand it then to give
required obse
Rel that's total obsequious submission I
will do what you say whether I believe
it or not just because you actually said
it to the teaching of the ordinary
magian means to make an honest and
sustained effort to overcome any
contrary opinion I might have and to
achieve a sincere Ascent of mine to this
teaching I must throw the Bible aside
and make an effort to disbelieve the
Bible and accept this apostate teaching
your from these people you thrw your
conscience with it Rome has changed no
there's no way hey Martin don't you get
angry I I don't want to say angry I want
to call right I want to call it
righteous indignation and the problem is
it's against the system and these people
that are contradicting the word if you
are a sincere person caught up in this
wake up and get out okay let's take
another statement this is the official
text of the 1978 National catechetical
directory sharing the light of faith and
it states it is the task of the
catechesis that's the one
studying to elicit Ascent to all the
church's teachers teachers for the
church is the indispensable Guide to the
complete richness of what Jesus teaches
when faced with questions which pertain
to descent from nonin fallible teachings
of the church it is important for the
cateus to keep in mind that the
presumption is always in favor of the
magisterium no matter what they say
whether they speak ex Catra or whether
they don't it doesn't matter whatever
they say you say yes
amen only a system of tight
syllogism which leaves no room for the
personal oh you may not think for
yourself you must be dead in your brain
it's exactly the same that they had in
the Middle Ages and this is how Jesuits
think like a corpse obey like a corpse
that's the why they didn't want you to
read the Bible because you didn't have
any personal opinion on what in other
words get rid of your personal opinion
and that can guarantee certitude about
knowing and doing what God requires and
enables just do what the Pope says and
you will be right have they changed no
they've become more arrogant so let's go
to the second Vatican Council because
this is where our illustrious
theologians say that the change came
right so let's have a question did the
Vatican 2 Council change the Roman
Catholic position established at the
Council of
Trent well I can answer already yes no
why not because it teaches exactly the
same still and it can't because they're
INF infallible I forgot about that don't
you dare forget that it's infallible
Martin so there our Pope was carried in
as they did traditionally the modern
ones don't want to do this one anymore
because it seems so elevated they just
do it clandestinely in another way in
Incognito Incognito and sometimes in
plain sight yeah all right Martin
so our illustrious gentlemen said Rome
has
changed it's oldfashioned theology we
must distance ourselves from ourselves
from it so let's ask Rome itself yeah
cuz that's a horse's Mouse isn't it
let's ask the horse did the second
Vatican Council change the Catholic
Doctrine on the church and this comes
from their web page vatican.va
response the second Vatican Council
neither changed nor intended to change
this
Doctrine I'm sorry
you may not laugh I would like to send
this to the person that
was was quoting it he will discard it he
will discarded because he's been doing
it
for decades now rather it developed
deepened and more fully explained it we
just read how they developed and fully
explained it stop thinking and do what
you are told told finished right this
was exactly what John the 23rd said at
the beginning of the council
Paul v 6 affirmed it and commented on
the act of promulgating the Constitution
Lumen gentium we just quoted from it
exactly there is no better comment to
make than to say that this promulgation
really changes
nothing of the traditional doctrines
Martin are these people illiterate or
are they willfully
blind y it's a hard one right that's a
hard one I hope they're the first I know
that he accused me once of saying he's a
Jesuit but I never did because I didn't
even know him at the
time and I don't want to go that far but
willful ignorance seems to me
appropriate as far as I will go now what
Christ will we also will what was still
is what the church has taught down
through the centuries we also teach in
simple terms that which was assumed is
now explicit that which was uncertain is
now clarified that was which was
mediated upon discussed and sometimes
argued over is now put together in one
clear formulation and let me summarize
it for you we haven't changed but you're
so stupid you changed and you don't even
notice it that's what they're saying
we've told you that from the beginning
you should change and come back and now
you did thank you now you did so
argument settled Rome didn't change
now who were the architects of V Vatican
2 well one of them was car
r and what was he it was of course a
Jesuit of course one of the most
important theologians of the 20th
century kalana was born in March
1904 he was the fourth of seven children
the son of a local college professor and
a devout Christian mother in
1922 car followed his older brother Hugo
and entered the Jesuit Community as a
Jesuit novice
he was formed by the spiritual exercises
of ignasius Lola in other words it's
spiritualism that's it's got nothing to
do with the Bible and if you want to
read about spiritual formation or want
to look at a DVD on it the Jesuits and
The Counter Reformation part one and two
is something that deals with this this
formation had lasting influence on his
spiritual and intellectual development
they're not interested in the Bible they
have experiential religion
yes all right so this is Carana and one
of the Architects sitting with him now
not in a Jesuit little suit but in
colors and ties is ratzinger yeah who
became Pope right Pope
Benedict but I think that the
spirituality of ignatum himself which
one learned through the practice of
prayer and religious formation was more
significant to me than all the Learned
philosophy and the ology inside and
outside of the
order so spiritual formation is more
important than the theology or
philosophy it's what you think when you
become yeah stupified well just a little
side track remember we recently had
Steve Bannon who went to jail and he
clearly said to Taka Carlson when taka
asked him so what are you going to do
now that you're going to be in jail and
he said I going to exercise my spiritual
exercises of Lola correct so in his
studies R also became thoroughly
conversent with the thinking of the
fathers of the church especially on the
topics such as Grace the sacraments
spirituality and
mysticism he was a Mystic he was a
gnostic Mystic God himself on this Earth
mysticism is from the devil yes so here
they are ringa and Rana and what was his
motto his motto was and this comes from
Catholic Family
news our Lord must conform to the world
not it to him yeah Martin how far how
Rome changed in Vatican yes we have to
distance ourselves ourselves from any
that says that they haven't okay so he
undoubtedly one of the most important
Roman Catholic theologians in the 20th
century his seminal position amongst his
contemporaries resulted to some extent
from the ability to put Theology and
philosophy into dialogue mixing paganism
spiritualism with the word of God it's
forbidden to the law and to the
testimony and then he originated another
category called Anonymous Christianity
oh yeah those are people who don't know
that they're Christian like Buddhists
and atheists oh they're Anonymous and
they will go to heaven too they are part
of Christianity that does not call
itself Christianity pagans who have
received Grace but not aware of it so
that opens the door for a Floodgate Of
infidelity to come in so like the pope
recently said all religions lead to God
all of them correct and then his prot
Paul Neta who was trained and taught by
Carana comes up with this nonsense no
other name which then clearly according
to them proves that you can be saved by
any name doesn't have to be the name of
Jesus is this contradicting yes for sure
the scriptures contradict you want to be
part of this contradiction
Martin so what about the Catholic
catechism
surely that won't contradict the word of
God will
it the so Church of Christ which Our
Savior after his resurrection entrusted
to Peter's past care commissioning him
to and the other Apostles to extend and
Rule it this church constituted and
organized as a society in the present
world subsists in the Catholic Church
which is governed by the successor of
Peter and by the Bishops in community
with him so that's the
magisterium the second Vatican Council
decree on ecumenism
explains for it is through the Christ's
Catholic Church
alone which is the universal help
towards salvation that the fullness of
the means of Salvation can be obtained
has Rome changed no it's in their
catechism no
HH all right how far will they go
Vatican Protestants are not sister
churches no they daughter they are
children naughty children daughters
daughters and as children they are not
definitive it's the mother that's
definitive my children will return to
me all right the Cardinals note approved
by Pope John Paul on June 9th is to be
held as authorative and binding
according to Cardinal ratzinger's letter
to Bishop conference the four-page note
gives a detailed history of the use of
the term sister churches explaining that
it was used in reference to the Orthodox
churches with which Rome was in
communion for many
centuries however even on this point
Cardinal ratzinger claims Rome Superior
to other churches stating in this
connection it needs to be noted that no
Roman pontiff ever recognized this
Equalization of seas or accepted that
only a Primacy of Honor be accorded to
the Sea of Rome meaning that Rome had
has Superior Authority has anything
changed nothing
nothing so in his Dominos eus he plainly
states other churches are no sisters of
ours the Vatican
insists it must always be clear that the
one holy and Catholic and Apostolic
universal church is not the sister but
the mother of all the churches has Rome
changed no but then maybe the modern
Pope changed after R singer of course
because uh he is such a loving um Pope
and inclusive yes everything
goes all right what does zenet news say
in an article on Benedict's
speech it says already in the first
century popes exercised their Primacy
over the other churches that's what
Benedict says he's the boss the Holy
Father explained this on Wednesday at
the general audience which he did
dedicated to Pope St Clemens of Rome the
third successor of Peter he says Clement
letter clarifies the distinction between
hierarchy and Ley the clear distinction
between the lay people and the hierarchy
does not mean in any way a
contraposition but only an organic
connection to the body what is he saying
in fact the church is not the place for
confusion and Anarchy where someone can
do whatever he once at any time each one
in this organization with an articulated
structure practices his ministry
according to the vocation receive as to
pertaining to the heads of community he
specifies clearly the doctrine of
apostolic succession the pope is the
successor of Peter you will listen to
him then he
adds the laws that regulate this derived
from God himself oh did you know that M
I know now
as an ultimate analysis the father sent
Jesus Christ who in turn sent the
Apostle these then sent out the first
heads of community and established that
they would be followed by Worthy men
really deported ones especially in the
Middle
Ages the church is above all a gift of
God and not a creature of ours the pope
Contender and
therefore this sacramental structure not
only guarantees a common order but also
the Ence of the gift that we all need
and sacramental means salvation it's
salvational so accepting the pope as
your head is salvation yeah Martin is
that diabolical I thought accepting
Jesus Christ as your savior is
salvational the only
one uh is this confirmed by other
writers M well here's another Jesuit
Malachi Martin and he says that the
pontiff is the sole living
representative of God amongst men so
is endowed with absolute authority to
teach God's salvation as revealed
through his son Christ who was and is
God himself made man Catholic teaching
holds that any Roman Catholic any
non-catholic or any non-Christian of
whatever religion who receives God's
salvation receives it through the
spiritual Office of the man in Rome
that's it so he's Jesus he's God yeah
he's God Martin this is a letter that
was written by the free Presbyterian
Church of Scotland's Clark of the Senate
the Reverend Donald McLain's comment
regarding ecumenism let's see what he
said in 1988 he already wrote it he
stated The ecumenical movement which you
praise is the greatest disaster to
affect the Christian church in this Cent
Century I like that you like
it it has reduced the professing
churches of this country to a collection
of bloodless spineless and boneless
organizations which can hardly raise a
whimper on the side of Christ and his
truth Small Wonder that evil progresses
as it does and spiritual Darkness
becomes more intense as the years go by
you appear to regard a body of
professing Christians and I want to say
that to the very gentlemen that are
trying to bring in this new doctrine
yeah yeah you appear to regard the body
of professing Christians of sober
conduct and deep spirituality of Mind as
fanatical and bigoted if this be so then
the eminent men of God such as John Knox
in Scotland John Calvin and Martin
Luther in their continent and Archbishop
cranman England were bigots in their
contest with the errors of poy we are
glad to be in such company and I agree
with that you agree with him and I'll
also say you mentioned that person and
every other person that agrees with what
he's saying
yes okay now let's look at our present
Pope is he the one that brought about
the
change well Pope Francis says religion
should not be confined to personal
conscience you cannot decide for
yourself what you want to believe
right Vatican radio the orderly
development of a civil pluralistic
society requires that the authentic
Spirit of religion not be confined to
personal conscience but that its
significant role in the construction of
society is recognized said Pope Francis
in his remarks through independent
church and state the common
responsibility of meeting people's
spiritual and physical needs with
humility and dedic he said so who must
you subject your conscience to to the
pope and to the church to to him and the
magisterium and he's here acknowledging
exactly what we've read what s I said it
started from the beginning exactly all
right Pope condemns religious
fundamentalism and Middle East violence
a fundamental group that's a group that
believes the Bible literally yeah even
if it kills no one even if it strikes no
one is violent the mental structure of
fundamentalis is violence in the name of
God has this man changed this Jesuit no
no this Jesuit is still a Jesuit and he
is a kindred spirit of PETA Faba MH who
together with his kindreds murdered
millions of people yeah so he calls
Christian
fundamentalism let's define it exactly
that's believing what God said
absolutely he calls it a
sickness he says is belief in the strict
literal interpretation of the Bible is
sickness Pope Francis appears to think
so just a few days ago multiple
reporters heard Francis describe
fundamentalism as a sickness that is in
all religions including
Christianity what is fundamentalism if
you go to Google it is defined as a form
of religion especially Islam or
Protestant
Christianity that upholds belief in the
strict literal interpretation of
scripture so does Pope Francis really
intend to combat those that believe in a
literal interpretation of the Bible
obviously yes because he says it's a
sickness yeah well I think has he
changed any doctrines of the Roman
Catholic Church No in fact he's
supporting it Pope Francis calls for
Unity between evangelicals and Catholics
he calls the division the work of the
devil was Jesus divisive
yes I have not come to bring peace but a
sword division is the work of the Father
of Lies the father of Discord who does
everything possible to keep us divided
Francis said in a video message how do
you do that Martin well he tells us how
let us put Doctrine aside oh yeah easily
let's become philanthropists Rome has
changed no no why must he put Doctrine
aside because he's infallible and he
can't change it no so his Doctrine
contradicts the Bible contradiction yeah
anybody who agrees with Pope Francis is
contradicting the word of God EXC and
has become an enemy of God and if you
align themselves with them you are in
the same category yeah all right so
let's continue a picture speaks a
thousand words exactly you don't have to
S anything if you know your Bible what
is this picture of there he sits on the
great white throne with between the the
cherubs with four living creatures
around him he's he's copying the Throne
of God by this picture he's sending a
message that he is God MH and you will
obey him and you will contradict what
God has said or else he will get rid of
you for sure has Rome changed no and
like we mentioned he's just doing it a
little bit more Incognito yes so he
won't say it so bluntly but he shows it
bluntly he shows it bluntly and in his
statements couched in fancy little words
he is displaying the same despotic
character that has been displayed
throughout the centuries you see the
other thing that he also
does just explain quickly what ponteix
Maximus means that was the title of the
Babylonian priest king yeah he was the
Supreme pontiff the Supreme father the
Maximus and it was the title that was
given to the head of the Babylonian
system in pergamum yeah and that title
was bequeathed to Rome by aalos III on
condition that the Roman Emperor be
worshiped as God Julius Caesar is the
one who took up that challenge and
accepted worship and from Julius
Caesar's day on temples were erected for
the worship of the the emperor the early
Christians refused to go along with that
these so-called successors of Peter took
upon themselves that title when the
Roman pontiff in other words the
pontifex maxup the Cesar of Rome
abandoned the throne in Rome and he took
that title upon himself and therefore he
claims that he is God and that he is
worshiped as God and here he is
displaying it and then in Incognito just
in case somebody says yes but he doesn't
call himself ponteix Maximus oh really
if you look at his formly called Twitter
now X account it's act ponix
aha Martin therefore the statement that
they made that they want to repudiate
poy is just what prophecy declared that
she would be the apostasy of the latter
times it is part of her policy to assume
the character which will best accomplish
her purpose but beneath the variable
appearance of the chameleon she conceals
the invariable Venom of the serpent do
you want to negate that statement oh no
and I won't distance myself from that at
all we are not bound to keep faith and
Promises to Heretics she declares have
they done that yes he wasn't speaking
excetra so he can lie to you shall this
power whose record for a thousand years
is written in the blood of the Saints be
now acknowledged as part of the Church
of Christ when they deny the atonement
and make you pay for your own sins and
negate Jesus yeah and claim to be God
themselves when the religion of Christ
is most held in
contempt when his law is most despised
then should our Zeal be the warmest and
our courage and firmness the most
unflinching to stand in defense of Truth
and righteousness when the majority
forsake us to fight the battles of the
Lord when Champions are few the this
will be our test at this time we must
gather warmth from the coldness of
others courage from their cowardice and
loyalty from their treason I stand by
this quote me too let's pray amen
Heavenly Father we are seeing a great
apostasy raising its head threatening to
draw thousands of your people into the
abbis I pray that you will open the
hearts and mind minds of your people
that they may believe the prophets and
be established is my prayer in Jesus
name amen amen
[Music]
[Applause]
h
[Music]
[Applause]